a little gear review on the Superstock
ease and the glow sock boy both from
speeders these are the super sakhis both
sets they gave to me to try the mouse
with knob handles nice squishy knob
handles and then somebody at the PI
circus hospital asked me why I don't
through throws and he got me started so
I get his name already but dude you got
me doing throat so they're both good boy
and it's a bit the globe boy I for a
total beginner I probably recommend the
globe poi
even more because they've got just a
little bit of stretch in the fabric is
really soft so it just feels nice but
forgetting the tosses if you think you
want to throw and catch then I'd go for
super stockings because there's no
stretch at all holy zero stretch and
that makes for much cleaner throwing you
can even the globe play throw okay but
but these throw throw really well and in
general the recommendation by the way if
you're ever using sock toys sometimes I
feel like there's too much wind
resistance in all the Lloyd views
so I often will take an elastic or hair
elastic and put it around near the end
and that just makes it have a very nice
amount of of air resistance so also
they've asked the method yes they will
let you mix colors so you can go to the
website and order you know like a one
orange and one yellow because I think
it's really helpful to have two to be
employees especially when trying to
learn orbitals and hyper loops and a
bunch of other stuff like that so super
takis glow poi steamers calm and you get
that forget percentage but if you use
the link that I provide or you see
playboy sent you you get a 10% or 15%
you get a discount